okay we're ready
hi this is Medea Benjamin with code pink
Mic Check Mic Check Medea mãe de a
Benjamin B enj a mi n okay so we're here
in front of the Lincoln Memorial the day
before the president will give his
speech I'm still doing a Mic Check here
are we okay I might check my check oh
yeah all right oh okay this is how tall
people feel powerful is this good
all right thank you so much for coming
my name is Medea Benjamin MEP EAB enj
ami n I am the co-director of the group
code pink we're here today because we
want to denounce Donald Trump
politicizing and militarizing the 4th of
July which is supposed to be a day that
we come together for barbecues tofu
burgers bread fritters picnics
celebrations fireworks and instead he's
turned it into a very divisive time and
because he announced that he is coming
to speak here we decided to ask the Park
Service for permission to fly the angry
baby Trump limb that comes from Britain
and has been a favorite around the world
greeting Trump as he travels it's been
to France Argentina Scotland and many
other places and that balloon usually
flies a little bit off the ground but we
have had a very hard time getting
permission to bring the baby Trump
balloon a few feet off the ground we
will be here tomorrow we will have the
baby Trump limp but we're not sure it
will be able to fly which is why we have
the requests here let the baby Trump fly
but we do think it's important to oppose
what the president is doing I'm a DC
resident and we know that the last time
President Trump wanted to have a
military parade the DC residents spoke
out so forcefully and our
representatives in the City Council said
no way in fact they said exactly this
tanks but no tanks we don't want tanks
on the streets of DC and I don't think
that is just because it represents the
DC residents I think it represents the
majority of opinion you can see the
divisive news already that President
Trump has brought to this because he is
coming here
with not only tanks but he's coming with
bombers this is a time when the majority
of Americans want to get out of the wars
were already in in fact many voted for
Trump because he said he was going to do
that this is a time when we were 10
minutes away from launching an attack on
Iran something the majority of Americans
don't want to see this is a time for us
to say we want to live in peace and we
don't want an attack on Iran
we're glad the president is talking to
the president to the chairman of North
Korea we want diplomacy and we don't
think that bringing Sherman tanks from
World War two is a show of strength we
think a show of strength is allowing us
to have the July 4th holiday that we
normally have which is devoid of
partisan politics I also want to say
that it's pretty awful that he has given
the majority of the seats especially the
front half of the reflecting pool over
to his cronies people who have given
money to his campaign as well as to the
Republican National Committee why the
Democrats say they have not gotten those
tickets this is being paid for by us the
taxpayers and it is a misuse of
taxpayers money to use this for what
seems like a campaign stop for president
Trump so thank you for listening to us
we have two more speakers and then we'll
take questions
so my name is Tiger e TI GH e last name
berry ba rry I'm with code pink
I hold the permit for the baby Trump on
the Washington Monument mall area we're
gonna be on the southwest corner of the
northwest quadrant that's 17th in the
middle of basically the middle of the
Washington Monument Mall area we'll have
the baby Trump there and the baby Trump
will be what we call cold inflated but
we're still waiting on the okay we've
gotten okay's from Fisto flight
standards district office because the
the the Park Service gave us the wrong
permit that we needed so we're still
waiting on the permit for the rest of
the helium if we don't get it we will
still have the baby and we will have a
wonderful time
inflated with air it's going to be
inflated you're going to see it for
miles
thank you
my name is Anne Wright a NNW righ T I'm
a writer
retired US Army colonel I was in the
Army 29 years I'm also a US diplomat
resigned in 2003 against the war on Iraq
and I'm sorry our veteran that was here
is not staying with us right now because
he is one of the reasons that we are
challenging all of these presidents from
Trump Obama Obama Bush Trump on all of
these wars not only for the people that
were killed in the countries the United
States has attacked but as you see this
young man has his service dog because he
has PTSD the millions of Americans that
have PTSD that were in the military and
I think a lot of us that were not on
active duty have PTSD from what our
country's been through this decision for
the by the president trunk to have to
hijack the national holiday so it is a
Trump special day is wrong as a retired
military and as a former US diplomat I
mean this looks more like what would be
happening on one level you know like on
red square you bring in the tanks you
have the flyovers like that it's just
not what America is right America is
this is a time to bring all of our
people together to stop the device that
we have politically which are severe but
at least come together for one little
day to say well we were founded how many
hundreds of years ago on the 4th of July
so as a military person and as a
diplomat I say it is wrong and that we
should be able to let these little baby
Trump things and 20 20 feet of them to
fly to show the opposition that we have
not only to the wars that that Trump is
in but the wars that we have had and the
and to say to our politicians no more
war thank you
so we also want to tell you some of the
things we'll be doing tomorrow we will
have a festival Trump is a big baby
festival we'll have an open mic for
anybody who wants to come and talk about
how they feel about the July 4th
celebration we will also have music and
dancing
we'll have comedians we will have a
reading from the federal Frederick
Douglas July 4th and